the night pants nation tour continues
breya california i'll see you this
thursday night at the brea improv 8pm
jason ellis and brenton biddlecombe will
be with me
august 5th through the 7th i'll be in la
jolla california and august 18th through
the 20th you can catch me in
philadelphia pennsylvania tickets for
those shows and all shows are available
on my website at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
if you're watching this show please hit
that subscribe button set a little
reminder it's a free easy way to help
the show i'm promise you it helps you
don't have to buy anything if you're
loving it and watching it boom just hit
subscribe all right if you gotta have
more honeydew and who doesn't
got the honeydew with you all y'all all
right it's five bucks a month it's on
patreon
and
i'm highlighting the low lights with
y'all and they are the wildest stories i
promise you you've ever heard in your
life you sign up for a year you get over
a month free you're getting the honeydew
a day early you're getting it ad free
and you're getting it at no additional
cost all right
uh if you or someone you know has that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together and right now if you're
watching i think there's a maybe a
couple more episodes left
um we are releasing 10 of our favorite
episodes of patreon on the regular
honeydew channel so you can go back and
check them out every thursday
um so you get a full sample of what the
patreon is like and i promise you these
are
10 crazy ass stories and there's a
shitload more all right the night pants
nation tour rolls on thank you guys for
your support because of you i've been
able to sell out a show or two in every
city i've been in and that to me is
victory so brea this thursday the 30th i
will be there with jason ellis and
brenton biddlecombe la jolla august 5th
through the 7th philadelphia i'll be
there august 18th through the 20th and
austin texas i will be there labor day
weekend september 2nd and 3rd get your
tickets to those shows and all shows at
ryanstickler.com now you know what we do
over here uh we highlight the low lights
here y'all these are the stories behind
the storytellers and i am very excited
to have this storyteller
back on the honeydew
ladies and gentlemen the cry champ of
the show jeremiah walker welcome back
it's gonna be back
you'll be back playing
back on the honeydew
oh i love when you do it all right first
of all it is really good to have you
back dude
it's always amazing to see you man
we have had um
if you haven't seen jeremiah's last
episode you gotta go watch the episode
um
it's when i really think cove had
manifested in this room all the all the
boogies and the tears and everything uh
yeah the fluids um but
um it was a great episode and uh i'm
very excited to have you back because
you
you know i do hope you went and talked
to somebody you left here just shaking i
was chef she's like he's got you he had
a shawl and you didn't even come in
whether you're just i knitted my own
sweater
and then and then right into the camera
with the promo and that's what makes me
love you and comedians
so much so welcome back
uh before we get into anything please
plug promote everything awesome i have a
new series called stand up on the spot
that's available for free on youtube our
buddy ryan sickler uh did the first
episode out we've got a new episode out
now that we did in moon tower in austin
texas with kelsey cook kurt braunholler
cypher sounds josh wolfe and myself it's
a great episode that you can watch for
free now
jeremiah wonders and scissor bros on my
other podcasts and then you can also see
me live july 8th in napa california and
then july 10th in honolulu california
tickets at jeremiahwatkins.com
there's a honolulu california honolulu
california
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hold on
i was like bro i'm nailing this i'm like
going right down the barrel i got it all
memorized is so professional locked in
give it all his [ __ ]
comes in here
hold on we're wrapping this podcast out
there we're coming at you from honolulu
honolulu california
take us to jeremiah
jeremiah stand up on all socials
all right go see jeremiah yeah yeah
okay so um
one of the things you talked about last
time was uh
a story that should have and could have
just gone so well with dave chappelle
and then it just was just oh just
cringe worthy and it ended up being very
unfortunate so yeah those are some of
the things you know we talk about a lot
of heavy [ __ ] on this
uh as you did last time as well on this
show and um we're gonna start off with
another story that you were like sickler
i had another i got another one for you
and uh and then we're gonna get into
some some journal entries again yeah
does that sound good that sounds great
all right so please take it away so just
to give you guys a little behind the
scenes
there were a few people that i texted or
called right after this happened
and it was jamar neighbors willie hunter
and ryan sickler
the wave and me
cause i hit up stickler i was like bro
i just like had such
it's i would say it's
officially my new biggest bomb story
i've ever had in my life
and this is
now this is our job
so is this also forget about bomb is
this also a
the biggest maybe like job fail as well
i think so it was the biggest swing and
a miss i've probably ever had and and
and what you know about me when i swing
i put my whole
body my fiber everything into it i
commit a thousand percent so
at the end of the day you know like i'm
going to go for it
uh so
this is a story about
uh how i auditioned for a show called
wild and now
i've already left
yeah there's not many of us just sort of
cracked wild enough pete davidson's
been a few other guys that have been on
oh and they let us know that when we got
to
yeah they went down the rolodex of
people who
have moved on to better things but
wilden out was the platform that made
them right they really like you know
drilled that in so
uh i happen to know uh one of the
producers uh like uh and casting over on
the show
and
they say i can do
uh submit a real basically and then
like we'll see if i hear anything back
right and what sort of real do you have
to submit for a show like that because
you that's a lot of live interaction
with people and seeing their appearance
and [ __ ] like that like a lot of the
dozens type of stuff so i put together a
really solid reel obviously if i got
they said that basically they did go
through like
i don't know this is true but they said
they went through like thousands of
submissions like that
who knows if that's the real number but
they narrowed it down to 15
and i was one of the 15. and what are
you doing on your auditioning like your
mom was so fat her blood type's ragu are
you doing that how are you doing a
little bit of that
a little bit of that
like uh what
oh okay so this is one of my jokes i
submitted on the reel that i remember
are you just talking the camera oh yeah
you're looking right in the camera
you're doing like a very presentational
like because i've had to do like a lot
of character reels and stuff like that
for sketch and different uh shows over
the years and stuff like that to submit
and one of them um
uh one of the dumb jokes
they have different categories basically
where they're like can you write a joke
for this
category of like
watch some games from the show
do your own jokes from those different
categories of games yes so one of mine
was a silly one i was like uh
my baby mama is so dumb
that that when we went to the gas
station she thought e40 was a type of a
gas you know something like that and
then i was like ooh you know something
that i just butchered my joke but anyway
um
so i submitted the reel
heard back that i get selected they put
us in the zoom
where
they say that
who's us
how many people are on this zoo
me
one other white guy
and then
13
other
different black girls and black guys
okay so 15 people yeah and you and
another white dude yeah and then like
there's like maybe one or two other
white girls like yeah that are in the in
there as well okay so i'm like i'm like
okay well that's that's the guy i have
to be like for the
the gig essentially right
and uh they start going down the list of
like they start kind of drill
sergeanting right away being like not
all of you are going to make it
boot camp right now right away
right away
they're like
not all you will see
the tv side of this show and they call
it a boot camp weekend they call it like
yeah it's literally like like a four day
camp or you go
and you test to see if you're wilding
out material
so
have do they tell you if anyone has left
crying
there's definitely been people that have
left there probably because the guy who
runs it is an intimidating guy yeah he's
a guy who's probably six foot i'm six
three he was probably six four six five
yeah big black dude very intimidating
and uh he was
he would tell people he would break
break people with habits
like at this at this camp like if
somebody had like a nervous thing where
they they they um put their hands in
your pockets there's this guy
who that was his tick he he would look
down and he had his hands in a hoodie
and he kept going take your hands out
the hoodie and the guys are high high
this is day one of camp this is day one
again
yeah and and by the way so that so just
uh let's get back to the zoom call
because not everybody's getting to camps
all right we jumped in all right
so they tell us first that um they're
going to start eliminating people
in the room of the 15 people that were
there in front of other people for the
reality version because they are going
to film
this behind the scenes and put it on
youtube as a youtube special
so every step along the way is filmed
reality tv style so when i got
confirmation that i got it when i got in
the room they're like
some of you are going to get caught
right now and we're like what you just
told us that we were flying out
that we got it right
and
basically they said actually nah all you
were coming to camp
we got you kind of thing so already
starting off i'm like i don't like the
tone of this at all like i don't like
you know what i mean i don't like the
reality tv side of stuff at all
and so the 15 that were in the room
we all get flown out to atlanta to do
this workshop
called the workshop weekends right
so can i just go back for one second
there's 15 of you on a zoom call yeah
and they say you're all coming to
atlanta
and now it's like very american idly
like okay you got your golden ticket you
come to atlanta you know that kind of
thing and then you're all and then
b-roll jet leaving lax
now we're in atlanta we see some more
shots of atlanta some hip-hop some
atlanta hip-hop down there and then boom
now you guys are walking into yeah with
yeah
the suitcase is all stars in their eyes
yeah yeah uh
this hasn't the the youtube special
hasn't come out yet so i have i'm seeing
it i know
it's
oh no no you you already have the vision
for what they're gonna do i have no idea
how bad they're gonna make me look
that's the thing that's the thing i have
no let me ask you this do you know
anyone that has made it
yes they know they already started they
filmed the whole season they filmed it
like right away
you know i mean when you got
you were one of the 15 did you know any
of them prior to starting this job i
knew a couple of the comics that were
yes that were in the mix that were they
were also like so now you get to atlanta
yeah all right so i get to atlanta i
guess from atlanta and they start doing
a very
like
they're trying to scare people and test
their nerves right away they're
literally that's what they're trying to
intimidate people to see if you can get
shook right who wants to take you to
like baltimore or chicago and put you on
a corner and be like you got to make
these people laugh
yeah um
as soon as i walk in uh one of the
current cast members is already making
fun of me as soon as i step off the
elevator
as soon as i step off the elevator bro
i'm still waking up
and then it's like and he's like look at
this guy right here got them flatbread
shoes on right here these flatbreads
because i i got long feet and i was like
oh this is pretty funny i'm like hey i'm
jeremiah
[Music]
like they're wanting to roast but that's
just how they're communicating that's
just
the vibe of the show you know
i'm trying to meet different people and
i'm like kind of like other people
literally multiple people start roasting
me like as soon as i walk in the room
and like i'm just like smiling nodding
and they're like oh why don't you say
anything back i'm like i'll show you out
there like i'm good i'm it's nice to
meet you like like i never like right
away like i'd rather prove myself like
in the performance space than go at you
like
you're a lights on guy i'm a light song
guy you're not a practice guy no no no
i'm like i'll see you on the field yeah
right
so see you guys on the court yeah yeah
pretty much
pretty much like all right i got you i
got you yeah all right so the guy who's
in charge of the workshop he's started
barking at people right away to get
inside their heads so so this guy who
has the pockets issue he keeps yelling
at this dude where like it's
really uncomfortable for me and all the
other people and like i've been around
like some bad casting excuse me his name
after this you don't have to say it oh
well yeah i want to know after this i
will say no this was one of like after
it was all said and done this was one of
my least favorite casting experiences of
my life it sounds traumatized it was it
was literally traumatizing
this is the first day he starts yelling
at this dude who has a pockets issue
dude
no listen this is wild now okay
listen we respect women
everybody here as well listen
everybody's here welcome so this guy he
he he's having trouble because it's an
obvious nervous tic he keeps putting him
back in after he says stuff and he goes
do you want to go back to tick-tock
because that's where you're going to go
after this
and i'm looking around like
what is happening he goes we found you
on tick-tock and we can return you to
return
i am i'm like almost sweating looking
around i'm just like this already this
is just not how i interact like and
these are supposed to be like improv
workshops dude everything that i've
learned about improv is supposed to be
like
nurturing and supportive of other people
yes and everything where's your space
work at man right yeah but this was so
aggressive that i was like oh i'm gonna
have to
literally re wire my brain for this
weekend because i this is not how i just
don't interact with people in general
like that
so
uh he starts
there was one girl who got so upset with
the guy that she ended up um wanting to
talk with him outside and he goes if she
wants to talk to me outside she can just
go home
and she did
she's like gordon ramsay of this thing
yeah right yeah black gordon ramsay
urban urban galaxy slash gordon brown
okay all right so he's doing all that
he's being
extremely intimidating uh and now we're
down to 14 people you're telling me
because that was like by day two or
something so they're eliminating so wait
they really did make people fly all the
way atlanta and get killed on the cut on
day one that was her choice she
technically wouldn't have gotten cut had
she not she literally would have liked
that for the reality oh yeah no she she
literally was like i'm going to
stay in my room like i'll talk to him
when he like she goes i'm not talking
with him in front of everybody else he's
like well she's not an exception to the
rules so we can figure this out later
but like we got to move on with the
workshop there's other people in here
that got to do the workshop
so
i start proving myself
i start doing my thing and i have a
knack for improv i've been doing improv
for many many years
probably like 15 plus years at this
point
and i started proving myself as like
i started killing in the workshop i
started doing really really well where
the guys who were making fun of me
before kind of started being like hi
this guy's kind of funny and just paint
a picture
is like everybody has a lot of bravado
like who is in
the sessions because there's current
cast members who are there to work with
the people who are not a part of the
cast yet so
there's a lot of people trying to prove
themselves and then there's a lot of
people who are already settled into the
show they've been doing it for years and
they're just kind of like like this is
what i do this is how it's done
so
there's a kind of like uh that hip-hop
mentality was like
trying to prove you're tough like all
the time and like like machisimo there's
a lot of that energy around
and uh
i'm not the most you know
that's funny you got a pineapple [ __ ]
shirt button up right now
oh luckily i was smart enough to wear
pretty neutral colors like ahead of time
i was like i'm just going to wear like a
hoodie and a gray shirt or some other
earth tones yeah yeah yeah exactly uh so
the first day i'm doing really really
well
and uh i they started noticing i started
uh being like okay this dude is funny i
start like getting props from different
people after we do the different
um improv games and riffing like music
stuff and different things like that
and
by the end of the day i'm like oh i got
this i got like this is gonna be no
problem for me to join this cast and
that's when i got
overzealous was the first day
because this is what happened
one of the uh members of the current
cast uh is a trans woman
and she
let everybody know
at the beginning of the workshop the
beginning of the day she said i don't
care what pronouns you call me i don't
care what you refer to me as
like just know that if you come at me
i'm coming to you twice as hard so you
better be funny whatever you say
but whatever you say is totally cool by
me she said it in front of everybody she
said in front of the producers and i
took mental note of that
at the end of the day for the first
workshop day after everybody like had
started being like oh this dude is funny
like and i'm feeling myself and
everything like that i'm like okay
i'm gonna go somewhere where all these
like tough guys won't go with their
comedy right
and at the end of the day they do this
this game called the wild style they do
at the end of every wild mount tv show
okay it's like tradition so everybody's
starting to freestyle rap battle each
other
and when the producer sees that i
haven't gone yet he's like hey have you
not gone yet i'm like no he's like get
up here i was like okay
and i go i want candy that's the name of
the the trans girl
and i want candy
so all
all the tough guys are already like
all right like
like that's probably the first time
she's heard that
you know that kind of like like
uncomfortable already that i said that i
want candy like calling her out like
that
so this is what i say
oh man this is like when you first go to
prison and you're like who's the biggest
[ __ ] in here that's exactly what
it is i'm gonna punch you in the [ __ ]
mouth and i'm gonna show everybody who
the [ __ ] i am in this cell block yeah
you were like let me take the biggest
challenge
that's exactly what i did right
so i start freestyling i go i'ma suck
your dick i won't make it real quick i'm
gonna take you to the van that's my plan
i was like i'm gonna go hard
on this
and
basically see
what their reaction is because they're
never going to say any of this stuff
because they're all tough dudes who
they're not going to make trans jokes
like that and i'm like
i'll go in a territory that they won't
touch and it'll be a fun funny asset for
the show
when i said the first line
literally i'm gonna suck your dick
all the black guys in the room go
and you know me
get your hands on your hoodie
you're moving them a lot in there now
man i don't know what's going on
i keep going
of course
of course you do i keep going
dude every line that i say
all the black guys in the room start
going
they are so disgusted and so grossed out
by what i'm saying the head producer
looks like he's going to start vomiting
he's so like
they don't know what to do they're
looking at me like this crazy white guy
what's candy doing though
she's like okay
[Laughter]
like really surprised though really
surprised that
that i went in a posit i went in a
positive direction
that's what i thought would be funny i
was like i'm gonna go make this a
positive thing
go in a non-roasty area
you know go for something that nobody
else would ever they would never never
when i say
that it literally like real quick yeah
set the stage for me literally how many
people are out there right now in front
of seeing all that i'm how many people
are in the room cameras are rolling
cameras are rolling there are about
three or four cameramen
all different angles kevin love what is
their audio guy or they got yeah
how many people are in this there is
eight to ten producers
there must be twenty people in this one
with all the cast with the crew with the
cast there's at least
somewhere between 20 and 30 people
it's a lot of people that's a lot of
people
and i'm going in i'm like i'm acting
like i got bars because dude freestyle
rapping like as far as improv goes
they're such different things they're
such different muscles and i'm like i'm
going to be funny with this like because
freestyle rapping is not my forte music
improv i can music improv for days but
it just is different
so every line that i go in they start
getting more and more grossed out and
disgusted with me and at what point are
you starting to shift to see the eyes
and and really hear what's happening yo
i start
laughing a little bit because i know
that they're not lying but i'm like but
i gotta see this through i gotta keep it
i gotta keep going
and
you know
in a saloon when a new person comes into
town in an old west yeah
everybody just turns and it's silent
they stopped the wild style
the dj goes
[Music]
no
he had he was up there they were really
doing it
they had the guy the dj who dj's every
episode he literally went bro
[Laughter]
you heard that
that noise stopped a real moment in your
life
dude
do it again
candy's like oh my god
oh man because she's i don't even
remember what she said back to me she
started she started battle wrapping me
back and then i went in for a second
helping oh
wait what did you end on the candy was
like imma let you suck my dad
you can take this
i dude i blacked out like you [ __ ]
finished and then she went back she went
back and then i came back for more
and then literally
the producers he literally stepped in
between us he's like all right enough hi
hi
all right we're done
that was
they ended the freestyle for the day
that's how we ended the first day yeah
it's like a fight at football practice
he's really gonna do it he's showering
he's gonna tuck her down
[Laughter]
oh
man
so
so what happened next
we do we have to do these exit
interviews
oh wow
why
because reality tv
so they had all the uh all the comics
doing uh
oh [ __ ]
questions based on how they think
they did for the day and stuff like that
this is what i get yelled at for
stopping asking questions but hold on
at the end of that day
after that whole thing's over what do
you do you go back to your hotel that
night do you hang out any of the cast
does anyone talk hey is there a little
[ __ ] fist bump from from the grip on
the way out is there anything that you
get from anybody here's what happened
everybody who was a fan of me before
hates me now
it's like i have gay leprosy and they're
worried that they're gonna catch the gay
because they think i'm gay now
because i joked around
they think i'm gay
and we're in atlanta and they're like
that's not cool man
that's not cool
so on my exit interview
i they're like would you have done
anything different today i go
did you see the wild style
i was like a little bit of a car fire
oh
god
so
was that just the next day that was dude
this was the first day of the workshop i
had killed the whole first day and at
the end of the day that's my lasting
impression was that that's how we did
that morning was your exit interview no
no we did exit interviews after every
day of the workshop
right so it's like daily exit interviews
so i called my wife
and i told her i'm laughing i go
if
i said this might happen i said i might
have lost this gig today because i said
the way they react i said it was it was
like a homophobic reaction they saw no
comedy in it which i was like i'm
bringing comedy to this like i'm like if
i lose this candy was like shut up shut
up
[Laughter]
the next day
that i go in day two
they do they say that they're gonna make
cuts every single day right
the next day i go in um i was like
they'll for sure keep me because i had
such a strong first part of the day that
was just
a bad thing whatever
so i do make it into the second day of
the workshop they welcome everybody and
they didn't cut anybody the second day
they're doing these mind games where
they're like some of you are going to
get cut and then we all they let us all
back in and there dude there were some
people in there who literally had never
done any live performances before they
were only from tiktok
there's people who have no performance
experience at all whatsoever so like
it's a mixture of like a lot of like
internet personalities mixed with only a
handful of like actual stand-up comics
who tour or people who actually have
proper improv training stuff like that
just to paint the full scope of what's
going on here so
the second day now i'm back there
nobody wants anything to do with me
they like i'm having trouble like i'm
that kid who's looking around like when
you're supposed to pair up with people
to do different things
like
they do not want any part of me nobody
so i keep pairing up with candy
i was about to have where is it she was
cool she she got the joke she got the
jokes she thought it was funny
and um
and uh
i feel like the producers are starting
to pull back from everything i'm saying
you know when somebody's like doing the
thing with you
where
you are
you you talk to somebody in the crowd
and you can you can tell they're trying
to not laugh they're putting up like a a
front to try to be quite cool
i felt that with like all the producers
and like the other people that were like
in the workshop right
and uh nick cannon comes in the second
day and i'm doing well with the props
and different things and different like
games and stuff that they have uh that
he's seen uh us do have they briefed
nick yet
no uh no but i'll i'll get to that in a
second i'll get to that in a second
about about where i think this is going
down
but so for example how i was like uh
i knew that people were like oh this
like they were like against me because
they thought that i was gay and stuff
like that
very weird so during one of the breaks
one of the guys who's auditioning for
the show
he has a little debbie cosmic brownie
you know those are the sprinkles they've
got the different like rainbow sprinkles
on top right
i walk up to this table excited him and
a couple other guys are chilling i go oh
man they got cosmic brownies here dope
where'd you get that he goes eka get
that gay [ __ ] out of here dog
and i go
i go what rainbow sprinkle
i go what
i i he goes yeah man he's like yeah get
out here with that i was like
they're called cosmic brownies
that's literally the name on the box
from little debbie goes
oh i won't wear that okay
he thought i was being like cosmic
brownies
[Music]
[Laughter]
so like people like they're literally is
so weird dude they're like like they're
like but also the fact that you think
that you're just doing something gay by
calling them cosmic i know yeah that's
how like insecure like and i told like
like when people were like saying like
like because they kept calling me gay
like whenever i would say stuff
like about like uh whatever they'd be
like yeah all right you're gay man like
they'd say stuff like that and i'm like
dude i'm like i'm comfortable with my
sexual i'm like i got a wife and a kid
they're like yeah okay
all right for all of your summer travels
whether you're going abroad or staying
domestic and want to immerse yourself in
the culture now is the perfect time to
start babel babel is the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions
thanks to babel's easy bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language before you reach
your destination with babel you only
need 10 minutes to complete a lesson so
you can start having real-life
conversations in a new language in as
little as three weeks other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 150 language experts their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different language including
spanish which is the one i chose french
italian and german okay and then babel
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and your
accent and there are so many ways to
learn with babel in addition to lessons
you can access podcasts games videos
stories and even live classes plus it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
so start your new language learning
journey today with babel right now you
can save up to 60 percent off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
honeydew that's
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com slash honeydew for
up to sixty percent off your
subscription babble language for life
this podcast is sponsored by better help
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped attachment
fatigue
and more i'm look i know for me i get
exhausted i want to lay down all the
time want to take a nap i want to just
have no energy you know and we associate
that burn out with work a lot of time
but that's not the only cause any of our
roles in life can lead us to feel burned
out and better help online therapy wants
to remind you to prioritize yourself
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours the honeydew listeners
get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
honeydew that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-dot
slash honeydew for 10 off your first
month now let's get back to the do so
i'm doing pretty well the second day
there's definitely you know you're
improvising for like eight hours so
you're gonna have hits and misses and
stuff like that but i'm like
on the on the accident interview on day
two i was like they're like uh how do
you feel like you did blah blah i was
like i feel good like they're like do
you think you'll make the cut for
day three i was like oh yeah definitely
you know i had a very strong day
especially in comparison it's a workshop
too they're teaching you brand new games
you're learning how to do them along the
way and stuff like that
uh
and i was like yeah no problem
third day comes right wait you started
to say especially in comparison
especially in comparison to oh they're
just
you're learning there's some people who
are
when i say bad at improv i can't even
tell you how bad it is where i'm
watching i'm like oh well they're
getting cut first they're getting cut
first
there's so many people that are just not
experienced where they have stage fright
they can't even they can't control their
voice they can't control the shakes in
their hands literally they have no stage
presence they just don't they just don't
don't have experience uh
so day three rolls around and they do
this thing where if you see your name
tag out on the table then that means
that you
get to go into the room
so i'm there with everybody else and i'm
looking around there's a couple people
that i had made friends with
uh and a couple people that i knew i'm
saying what's up too and whatever
and but the majority of people are still
kind of like kind of like side eyeing me
whatever
and they put all the name tags out and i
see my name tag i'm like great i start
to walk in and then they go uh
reset everybody we made a mistake
and i was like that's weird he goes they
go everybody put your name tags back on
the table
and
we all put our name tags back on the
table and then
they tell us to go around the corner and
then walk back and then they're all
filming
my name tag's not there no way dude
oh my god
you put a sad mistake
reset when you walked in
they saw me walking in the room like
that's the guy that shouldn't be that's
how they did it instead of quietly
saying listen man
it was reset for the candidate they
needed to reset for the camera of course
that reality they wanted the reality
so
yeah cause that doesn't hurt making it
doesn't hurt yeah you expected it
getting to have it ripped away from you
how do you not
show that on your face in your [ __ ]
you'll appreciate this because i as soon
as that happened i was like oh no
i think it's me
you did you knew yeah yeah i was like is
it because right when you closed that
pin and stepped in they were like and
cut guys
[Laughter]
huh
oh do we need to i just pinned it yeah
[Laughter]
i walk back up to the table
it's obvious like my name tag's not
there i scanned i was like i was kind of
like under my brother like you i started
laughing alright you gotta be kidding me
this is me and then i that they have
cameras on me like sure right and i go
that's what i did i learned before i go
and then i was like okay yeah and then
they made me do an exit interview
right away after that and i was doing
that like because like i'm a competitive
person
of course i'm still i'm a little heated
because i'm like there's people who who
are still in the workshop that are legit
horrible i was the first one who got
caught dude oh you're the
first who got cut
like that too yes oh man the first
out of everybody no even the hoodie kid
stayed he stayed
[Laughter]
bro
yeah i think it says a lot about what's
going on there and what happened so they
are
um oh man now they're grilling me in
this interview being like when did you
know that you're gonna get cut and i was
like well you know honestly i had an
elevator ride up with one of the
producers and uh
felt a little off energy in the elevator
and i was like i think i'm gonna cut
today and we start talking because i'm
like they're like you seem like you have
a lot to say i'm like i was like
i was like
i wished everybody well with the
production they wanted me to do the
reality tv thing where they're like ah
this sucks whatever i was like you know
what i wish the producers and nick
cannon the best i really appreciate the
opportunity and thank you so much for
having me like that was my final that's
getting cut out oh for sure yeah for
sure
the thing that they're gonna keep
is uh they go
if there were to be one other person to
be cut over you who would it be i'm like
listen i appreciate you guys doing your
reality tv thing i'm not giving you a
name that's what i said
and they kept asking me over and over
and i'll say for the context of the
story that this comic's name is nina
okay
and they go uh like but if you they
literally were grilling me before i
could fly home i'm just like
i'm like okay fine you want a name
nina nina is horrible she's been failing
at every game if she is not cut ahead of
me i lose entire faith in nick cannon
this project everything if she's still
in there
and she wasn't there
she dm's me
later that day oh i'm so sorry you got
cut
i go it's all good you're getting cut
tonight you said that yeah
she goes ah you [ __ ] why would you
say that i was like lol like sorry
you're getting cut tomorrow that's i'm
like i'm being real with you you are
being cut tomorrow she goes no i think i
did pretty good i'm like oh she's
delusional never mind i'm i i'm not
gonna keep engaging in this
so i flew home uh a little bit after
that but and she's a cast member no she
she didn't know she didn't make it she
didn't make it she did not make it
i'll be wrong
no but uh before i left one of the
writers um that i'm friends with
he comes out he goes dude i'm so sorry
he goes i fought for you he goes he came
in on the second day after what i had
done on the first day was the dick thing
that really did yeah yeah yeah yeah he
he said that the second day that he got
in
when he walked in
the producers were only talking about
that the entire time that they were yeah
about the incident
like i was like the crazy like erratic
guy and he's like doesn't that make him
memorable to you guys like like why
don't you tell him to just avoid
that topic
and like
he'll be fine he's like he's like he's
like this dude's a really good comic
like he's a actual working comic
and he goes i try to fight for you he
goes didn't work out
i was like hey i appreciate it you know
so it was uh it was one of those things
where like i went for the joke and that
one joke got me fired
so when is this going to air when can we
see on youtube
probably any day because the first
season is already out oh it's only on
youtube uh well
this will only be on youtube this
special
thing
yeah so we'll see how they cut it it
could be a they could make me they could
make we we improv for eight hours a day
they could make me look like i was
bombing the entire time sure that you
know what i mean like that's easily
that's very easy yeah they could
literally just keep it part 20 seconds
of the worst here and there you go of my
jokes
yeah yeah so
you know
it's a very interesting place to be but
it's a good experience as soon as it
happened i was like well i got another
honeydew episode
what a [ __ ] cringeworthy one that's
right dude yeah
yeah
um
all right let's pick up and let's get
into some journal entries here i'd love
to hear there's a specific one you
wanted to tell
yeah so this one is from let's see here
now if you didn't see jeremiah's last
episode while he looks he brought his
journals last time and
went through some entries and came
across something that he hadn't really
dealt with and uh
you know he he he became
the only episode we've ever had to stop
recording for and get tissue i know
there we go all right um so
this one is just an odd encounter story
uh because i think that any comedian who
has lived in
uh
la long enough
has had an andy dick story
or several or several yeah uh
now
basically this was uh i met him at uh
second city one night when i was in i
was interning there and taking classes
and stuff like that and uh
we ended up going out with a group of
friends to like bars and stuff
afterwards so this is i'm gonna read
this entry and feel free to to interject
whenever
let's see here
um
comes right here
one of the craziest experiences occurred
since i moved to la
i met andy dick and now this is in
yeah what year is this
2010
okay this is
august of 2010. all right
one of the craziest experiences since i
moved to l.a met andy dick
uh josh mark and he were smoking weed
and drinking on the roof of the second
city josh said it's getting pretty crazy
out there uh
i gave it a minute and decided to go out
there so he's warning me because he
knows that i'm like fresh off the boat
from kansas i probably haven't been
around a ton of drinking and
weed and stuff and drugs or whatever and
like but i had at that point like with
family whatever
but he's kind of giving me a heads up
like hey andy dick's out there it's
getting kind of crazy i'm like okay
um so i gave him a minute decided to go
out there i sat down to hang out and
josh giving me his approval and
introduced me to andy dick i told andy i
knew his son and that i've done stand up
with him and he said who hasn't
it's a good he did
he asked me how old i was and i told him
i was 21. you're a baby you know nothing
about comedy he joked around some more
and said no you're doing great
we went into uh
the office and uh my my music improv
teacher was in there as well
and uh josh was showing andy dick the
second city network youtube and showed
him some of the videos on there after we
watched several videos he looked at me
and said why don't you have any videos
i actually have a lot i said i looked at
josh for his approval to type in my
youtube page
he said why don't you show me uh or josh
said why don't you show me your new 80s
music video
so i showed it to him and uh i had his
attention until um it cuts to a shot
where i'm doing a line of cocaine
uh he started asking everyone if they
had coke
right as soon as he sees you
in the music video in an 80s music video
i want some coke does anybody have any
cocaine like right away
attention gone from the music video i'm
like oh that's it
i did but it's a funny music video that
he saw that and it was like ready to
park your video yeah yeah yeah
uh
and he's like that was good i get it
it's like every 80s video rolled into
one
actually was really good how much did it
cost to make i told him several hundred
dollars and he seemed impressed
he offered me a beer and i said that i
was good he goes do you not drink
i replied no and he said you've got to
get into it big nose
yes
my god
you've got to get into it big nose
so [ __ ] hard
god people okay
by the way he doesn't remember ever
[ __ ] powering this guy of course not
[Music]
okay that's good and then he says
he said you got to get into it big nose
the pure don't do well out here okay
right
uh it seemed like that really annoyed
him is what i wrote he started hitting
on me as the night progressed and it was
super freaky
that's what i wrote
uh around 11 like hitting on you in what
way what's he doing uh like starting to
touch me and like massage massage and
just starting to be like kind of feely
and like that kind of thing
um around 11 josh said he had to get
home to his wife and infant and he was
closing up second city andy dick looked
at fred and i and said
we're going on an excursion
oh jesus christ yep and fred was saying
he had to go but i told him in a quiet
voice that there was no way i could go
somewhere alone with andy dick
that's a good call yeah yeah so we
decided to go to borders there's a bar
like on hollywood boulevard it's like
down the street a bunch of second city
people still go to or used to go to um
so we started walk on hollywood
boulevard and it was crazy how everyone
literally everyone we passed recognized
andy dick
we love you andy can i get a picture he
had a 12 pack of pabst blue ribbon and
was throwing out cans of people who
recognized him that he liked
if they said we love you andy here i
ain't a pops blur ribbon pbr pbr
all the while he's drinking a beer out
in the open he hands me the 12-pack to
hold so he can pass out more and i was
thinking this could end poorly we go to
borders and people are recognizing him
and it grew at an alarming pace
fred and i were like his entourage and
it was crazy to see firsthand what being
a celebrity is like girls were taking
pictures of them and he was groping them
and grabbing their boobs like right away
as soon as they recognized them ah let
me fail you know just
and and they were all okay with it and
their boyfriends were high-fiving andy
back
look at your crazy
i'm just i literally am still shocked by
it
it happened so many times where like
he'd be feeling up a girl and then like
the boyfriend be like oh andy dick felt
my girlfriend so cool man it's like so
that's why it keeps happening because
you're allowing it to happen
uh
and he was hitting on every guy and
tried to make out with me
my friend mike and others he was trying
to make out with you now he's gotten
there oh no he was getting handsy and
aggressive at this point he asked me are
you gay i said no he goes bye
no
a little bye
[Laughter]
i don't know
and he goes can i look at you
i said
i guess
he goes naked
and i go no
and so he also grabbed my nose multiple
times and said hong kong
so i guess josh from second city sent
mike and and our friend mark to check on
me because he knew that i went there
with fred and andy dick and the guy
second city was like
maybe i should send a couple of
reinforcements to see what's going on
there right so um i thought mike was
going to punch andy dick
when we went next door to the club
because he was so aggressively trying to
kiss him
the whole night andy was telling people
to buy him drinks and they kept doing it
one guy gave him a beer so he could take
a picture with him i got into a
dance-off with another guy dance-off and
that was fun
[Music]
a dance i used to do that at the clubs
like like when i when i couldn't find
girls to dance with i'd be like freaking
you want to go dude
popping and locking
and uh and it says uh here i said i
busted out the splits and a good
handstand
mike introduced me to girls did a
handstand and splits in this place and
andy no wonder andy dick's like are you
a little bit
i see the way you move your body
saw those splints i saw those splits can
i be the banana deer splat
um
mike introduced me to a girl and said
he's gonna be a star when we were
talking later he said
i'm 27 i'm too old you can do it i've
got your back i thought that was cool of
him to say i don't know if that was the
beer talking i don't know what that
means around 2 a.m the
uh
the bard closed the bartender gave fred
three waters and andy another beer he
was wasted at this point
um
mark came to pay his tab and andy put
his fingers all up in his nose and said
what does that smell like
he had been fingering a girl earlier
with his other hand he put his fingers
up his butt and called it a bussy butt
[ __ ]
it's the first time i've read this in so
many years
hold on
he's fingering a chick with like his
left and his own [ __ ] with his right
and then rubbed it together and called
him and put it up my friend's nose oh
god he called it a
[ __ ]
his [ __ ] ass and her puzzle that
that's how you get [ __ ] that's how cove
stuff you're right
andy dick patient zero jesus christ dude
yeah
yep
okay
it's funny because it didn't happen to
me
i would have popped off him
confessing what that was that that was
up your nose especially me like that
stays in there a long time i am
questioning why he didn't do it to you
i know
what if your friend also went smells
like a [ __ ]
wait a second
is that bussy
is that bussy that i'm smelling
yeah dude it smells like bussy yeah
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
okay go ahead i'm sorry
we left bordeners and andy projectile
vomited beer on one of the side streets
i wish this was borders i wish this was
the best
aren't you a little bi
okay okay so
some splattered and hit a kid he was
grossed out but laughed when he saw it
was andy dick what hat what splattered
the vomit splashed and hit a stranger
wait hold up andy vom projectile vomited
and it hits he he pukes in the alley it
hits a stranger that's walking by and he
laughs he laughs after he goes he
freaked out and then when he saw that it
was andy dick he laughed it off oh
how gross is that oh
he smoked weed out of a group of guys
van
is a real thing
after this we kept walking more people
recognized him that had their their
trunk popped in the middle of hollywood
recognizes andy dick he saw their
smoking weed he starts smoking weed with
these strangers in the back of the van
and we left fortunately before anybody
saw is what i said we kept walking and
he said he was going to walk while
peeing
i said dude
you're going to just piss your pants
and he ended up doing just that
fred and i tried to call cab for him but
he said he didn't have any money
for the next bit we tried to get him to
fred's car so we could could uh
could drive him home eventually we just
had to leave him at a hostel we went
near at the end of the night when fred
dropped me off we looked at each other
and couldn't believe this night just
happened
i found out that there are no rules when
you are a celebrity rules and social
interactions don't apply
it was kind of sad how everyone wanted
to take advantage of him he seems sad
most of the night it just seems like an
empty lifestyle
i went to sleep after 3 30 a.m
bro that's a good one bussie
came out of that one oh [ __ ] dude
dude give me uh give me another one we
have some time okay all right give me
another one let's see here
oh let me tell you about my worst new
years ever let's hear that this is a
rough one
do we need to get kleenex no no no it's
just more
like what's in this one what's that
smell like like anybody but nobody knows
dirty ass or their finger in some chicks
yeah the whole time yeah
oh this is just a cringe-worthy sad
new year this is my journal entry
third and it's very melancholy some like
when i would write in these
i'd sometimes write like while i was
feeling something so it's very like
whatever that emotion was it's amped way
up right when did you start doing this
and when did you stop doing this or do
you still do this i'm not as diligent as
i i mean this is word for hold her up
for a second just to the camera i mean
that is where i mean that is writing
this i used to spend like at least an
hour a day yeah yeah clearly look at
this um it's literally just like it's
very like detailed stuff
um this was thursday december 31st 2009
okay first new year's going into la okay
you're here already yeah i moved here
okay from kansas
uh thursday december 31 2009
this was definitely the worst new year's
eve i've had in my entire life
that's how it starts dude
[Laughter]
but i wrote that down oh man i wrote
that down
uh
i worked at starbucks from 1 to 9 30 p.m
there's a couple good things that
happened today i composed a melody on
the piano for a new song
and tammy got me free subway for dinner
i've been secretly feeling depressed
lately
i was homesick bad today i wanted to
celebrate the holiday with my family
holidays are always hard without my
family tonight for new year's eve i just
walked around up on hollywood boulevard
and watched people get arrested
i saw some really stupid people tonight
when i was walking back i saw a dude
fall flat on his face
i could not get a hold of multiple
friends i felt very alone tonight i felt
like i did when i first moved out here
here are my new year's resolutions some
are pretty lofty goals but whatever
you're right you are fiona
whatever number one this is for 2010.
here we go
stop working at starbucks how long did
it take you to do that
you know what i i
got very fortunate i'm still i'm still
i'm still gonna still pick up a show i'm
still kind of here and there you know
i'm a shift lead on the download player
you know that
don't tell nobody accounting can't be
giving out this pastries for free
[Laughter]
number two
become famous or begin making a name for
myself in comedy three start getting
paid for something comedic four being a
tv commercial five get an agent
six send mom money to help her out
that's a little bit lower than i liked
on the list
all in your defense all that [ __ ] before
that needs to happen before you can do
that right right it's true uh number
seven find a church eight start playing
the saxophone again those were my new
year's resolutions for uh eight of them
yep how long did it take you to get out
of starbucks
um
before 2012 okay uh
that's not at the beginning of 2012 i
started doing comedy full-time and
acting boom all right so within two
years for two years i read them again
read them again and let's see within two
years you're out of starbucks it sounds
like you've made money right for comedy
go again um yeah begin making a name for
myself in comedy
three start getting paid for something
comedic so that's still somewhere like
that that's very similar two years you
got paid for comedic yeah being a tv
commercial the thing that got me out of
starbucks was a national commercial
wasn't it it was for the chevy volt nice
all right yeah played it like the world
series and hell yeah stuff like that and
yeah okay yeah so there's that
get an agent like that was the thing
that i mean helped me get the tv
commercials like that and then did you
send mom any money
i did later on it's fine yeah what else
uh find a church did you find a church
uh i found churches but i did not like
them in l.a okay you know why because
it's like
it was like the
instagram of churches
it was so like about produced it was so
overly produced i
hated it i went
and they kept having hashtags
and stuff after things
and it was one of they were showing
teasers and trailers for their different
church groups it was this all-female
church group they like like every
wednesday
the women the strongest women in l.a
meet blah blah blah and then at the end
no lie it said god chicks
god chicks
and i looked at that and i was like i
hate this place i literally i cannot you
know what i mean i was like if this is
what l.a church is i'm good
and then there was a guy who was uh
using um
he was using a uh a ladder
he was using it in his
like
in his sermon for what as part of like a
prop
and i leaned over
this is like years ago and i was like i
don't i was like i don't even like prop
comics i don't like prop pastors either
prop pants
i was like this is too much he's up
there falling and hanging off yeah he's
doing practice and then he's
crucified up there yeah yeah like and
this is the mess yeah
yeah have a great summer right right
get me down gary yeah come on get your
hands out of your sweatshirt
dude you did all see i really
i'm a big believer in writing [ __ ] down
because when you write it down it
happens i think so too it does happen
there's no doubt it doesn't happen
necessarily maybe the way you want it to
or think it will or
or what but look at all the [ __ ] that
you wrote there within two years
it's boom they're mostly there what else
was it
um yeah it was have to send mom money
you had eight of them uh start playing
saxophone again which you also did
because i when i met you you were
playing and oh yeah yeah hello sex
because basically
i had um i told you it was great dave
chappelle story about your saxophone
last episode
i taken a short break from saks because
i didn't i didn't have enough room in my
car for like another big suitcase to to
bring out to la so i was back in kansas
and when i went home for christmas my
mom's like take it back out with you to
la
and start
using it she goes i think you'll use it
in your comedy
i was like really a saxophone and comedy
my mom had intuition as far as that goes
because i ended up using it all watching
different shows over the years yeah yeah
you have yeah yeah what else was on
there um
uh it was just more like comedy release
up in starbucks and yeah tv commercial
yeah you did all of it yeah [ __ ] yeah
from that person listen i'm telling you
uh you know they talk about manifesting
all these things write [ __ ] down i write
i journal every day and every night i
don't do it like this
this is something else i do the five
minute journal i do i do every day every
night
and um it's a daily thing that i has
absolutely it's changed my mindset from
glass being half empty to half full it's
done a lot of positive [ __ ] for me so
this is really great stuff dude thank
you thank you for coming back yeah uh
thank you for sharing this stuff um and
with the first time i saw a vagina yeah
let's do that
how old are you the first time you saw a
vagina
it could be anywhere too it could be it
could have been in a [ __ ] public pool
it could have been a strip club it could
have been a girlfriend i'm excited to
hear about you this is almost this is
like oh this is a 2011. okay 11 years
ago yeah how old are you
um how old are you 33. so 2022 your
first vagina all right deuces all right
double deuce is here let's hear her
and this is from my uh
this is my wife now
uh let's see
i mean are you coming fresh off seeing
this vagina we getting that energy the
vagina energy in this one here that we
got the melancholy
time stamped the date on this
it's not a ride yeah
i mean i literally my wife's name is
maya i said i saw maya's vagina for the
first time on february 12 2011. man just
before uh valentine's day
valentine's day are you on the cast of
wild and how caught up with valentine's
day oh purpose of course
other than one i saw at a rock concert
this [ __ ] did you see at a rock concert
some chick just being drunk out dude i
remember that uh
at a uh a rock concert uh i used to work
at morning radio in kansas city
and uh
i
one of the concerts that we hosted there
was girls that were flashing and then
one girl like wanted to amp it up a
little bit and she flashed her vagina at
this concert i was like whoa
so [ __ ] yeah yeah rock and roll
dude i said maybe it's better to say it
was the first time a girl got completely
naked in front of me okay and i
underlined that
then i said this i wrote this ziggler i
said vaginas are pretty cool
i'm starting to see what the fuss is all
about
[Laughter]
you're literally starting to see
what the fuss is all about oh my god
that's a pure kansas jeremiah right
there
is
from kansas the very thing [ __ ] that
runs this goddamn world he's like about
to see what the [ __ ] i'm starting to see
it i'm starting to see it
um
let's see
yeah and then i'd say like i prepared
the tech sheet for our conservatory show
which is like second city so by the time
i was done she was asleep
i love having her sleep over then it
just goes into i said i don't need my
teddy bear or spiderman when she spends
the night this is right
this is frightening
this is that just made me sweat right
there just reading that out loud
this is so great you should you should
scan ahead quietly
what do you mean teddy bear inspires you
to sleep with a teddy bear and
spider-man into my 20s a spider-man what
like a like a buddy you know
i don't know what you mean
you know he's got a [ __ ] in the
background
where he just pounded him back there
oh [ __ ]
you used to sleep with that for anxiety
what was it i think i just liked having
something to hold on i literally for
never never a pillow i grab a pillow no
i always yeah i always like i literally
into my freaking early 20s slept with a
like a teddy bear from childhood or like
a uh a spiderman it was like a stuffed
almost like a doll it was like this big
yeah like the kind you get at the
carnival yep exactly that kind of stuff
yeah
exactly that kind of yeah
what uh did any women ever see this have
you ever told your wife that
i think i would hide them when she was
clearly you knew to hide it yeah you
knew to her i know i knew to hide it
yeah yeah for sure
yeah
and what was that all when did you
finally wrap that project up
when did you finally stop sleeping
he said you know
[Music]
i don't know no
what did you stop doing that when you
got married like when you hadn't uh
when she was a consistent girlfriend
when she started spending the night and
stuff like that i was like i'm gonna
keep you guys in the closet do you still
have them oh yeah you do yeah you didn't
have a talk with them and let them go
and donate them or anything like toy
story no i think they're in my son's
room now you gotta pass that [ __ ]
anxiety on yeah they're out like
displayed yeah that's pretty well that's
that's a good that's a good full circle
yeah i'll tell you that's a good full
circle i will yeah uh jeremiah watkins
thank you very much for coming on here
and and letting us laugh at your low
lights um
you certainly have some really that
those are that's
they make my skin crawl oh dude so the
the entries are so cringe-worthy because
they're just so raw and
like i said i haven't read these in a
year since i wrote it so it's very much
like where i was at that place right at
that time in my life
you still seeing what the fuss is all
about you see oh i love the fuss yeah
hell yeah um promote whatever you'd like
again please check out my new series
stand up on the spot which our buddy
it's a great ryan sickler was a part of
he crushed his set it was so fun to riff
with you after you said i love that show
you've been letting me do that for years
good for you for putting it out there
yeah and i'll keep having you back i
love having you on it and then um
jeremiah wonders scissor bros at
jeremiah stand up on all social media
honolulu hawaii there it is on july 10th
napa california on july 8th
jeremiahwatkins.com jeremiah stand up on
all social media boom thank you again
for real and thank you all as well uh
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com talk to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you